Hello, James speaking.
Oh hi, it's Graham Burn here.
Is that James?
Yes.
Great, it's Graham here, I'm calling from Kells and Co.
We're an accounting firm.
I've just come out of an interview with a friend of yours, Tim Barnard...
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
...who looked to be a great candidate,...
...so we thought we'd make our way back through the references quite promptly.
You know Tim?
Yeah, I know Tim personally.
I've known him for a few years now.
How long have you known Tim?
I've known Tim from probably ten years.
How did you guys become friends?
Through footy, the footy club.
Right, fantastic.
He didn't strike me as a footy player.
He wasn't really a player, he was just more come in as a spectator sort of thing.
Oh yes, helping out around the club.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, fantastic.
He'll be dealing with higher-end companies...
...in his role, businesses, of profits of a million dollars plus.
Is he known to be good with money?
Do you know anything about that?
From my understanding, he helped out a lot with a few fundraisers and stuff like that.
Yep.
So yeah, as far as I know.
Any other examples of him taking on responsibility?
He helps out the treasurer a lot.
Oh, that's good.
And he does that a fair bit.